why why would they have a [__]
dungeon under a pizza place why would it
be there this poor guy who owns Comet
Pizza is just like yeah man some guy
just said on Reddit that we that we have
a dungeon where we molest kids and so
now people were coming in the shop with
guns telling us to show us the dungeon
and like these [__] mental I'm so duh
like mental
health is real like you need to
understand it and and we need to get
better as a people but like dude when
when there's guys with guns coming in
your shop because they're mental it's
like just it's so annoying dude it's
it's so I would be like as scared as I
would be as if somebody came to my uh
establishment with a gun because they
thought something was happening that
wasn't happening
I would be so much more annoyed I would
be like oh dude really man
you know what just shoot me you [__]
like you just you 4chan [__] Reddit
reading [__] that just you just
think that this happened because some
guy said it
you cook
have a [__] pepperoni pizza sit down
like it's so you know how annoying that
we got to deal with these [__] the
internet is so good it's so awesome but
it's so annoying for these [__]
losers that it for uh that they're just
like hey like I could just start a [__]
right now hey you know [__] um the uh
American Idol doesn't really happen
it's actually not Ryan Seacrest he died
20 years ago
and it's been a AI or a robot since then
Simon Cowell is actually a 400
pound woman now he transitioned and dude
you say that at the right time in the
right
[__] Chan eight chain whatever
they're on now 16 Chan dude you get you
get that going in the right time it's a
board news day
in [__] five years someone shoots
Simon Cowell because what some guy said
on the internet
the Internet isn't real and now we have
to deal with real consequences if you
think podesta is in the basement of a
[__] pizza shop in DC
just molesting you're crazy crazy crazy
crazy
[Music]
you're crazy